How do you know which influenza to use if there's somebody to choose from? On the right, there wasn't a setting for 2022.
That's correct. You realize that in any given year, there are nearly a thousand influences that are circulating through society.
Ridiculousness of getting a flu shot, they can only guess on which one is going to be the most virulent.
And they can only get about three different varieties in the flu shot, but you're going to be exposed to a thousand varieties and influenza.
Are you kidding?
The flu shot is not effective.
It's dangerous. You should not be getting flu shots. Okay.
This will go out to the public. I'm just giving you my opinion. You're still getting vaccinated with the information that's out there. You really need to educate yourself. That's my opinion. You can throw it out. All you want. You can probably acquire.
I consider that a compliment, but I have not a pro vaccine.
All the edge of things that they're putting in vaccines and what the damaging things that that's doing to your body.
How do you know which right program to use? You just got to try them and see which one seems to help you. There's no perfect way to know you can't.
So just try the different influenza programs. You feel like you're coming down with the flu, do the cold and flu, uncutting, do the different influenza programs. You're just going to have to run through them.
Same with your bacterial programs. Oh, there's I feel like I got a strep throat. I got a sore throat. There's a whole bunch of strep programs. You're just the after run. Some of them just run them.
They are hitting the right thing. They're going to have benefits. So just try them.